loving kind generous those are just some
of the words used to describe
daniel scully the first nevadan to die
from the coronavirus thank you for
joining us at 11 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez tonight orkomana
sits down with his family
one year later in a story that you will
only see on eight news now
orca denise and brian daniel scully's
family still can't believe he's gone
he passed away on march 15 2020 after
getting kovid19 and now
one year later i spoke to his loved ones
who were honoring his life
and legacy
[Laughter]
they say time heals all wounds but for
families who have lost loved ones the
pain is permanent
i miss him i miss him all the time
daniel scully was the first nevadan to
die from kovid19
one year ago at the age of 69. most of
his family lives in chicago
including his sister [ __ ] who describes
him as a beautiful soul
he was just kind he was good to people
and he was kind of a solitary guy but
those that he let in he was he was a
good friend too
adding to the anguish [ __ ] also lost
her mother ida to the coronavirus
just two months after daniel's passing
we spent the last year not just
missing him but missing the family unit
daniel was a lover of baseball and took
[ __ ] to her first cubs game
his cousin robert missing their constant
conversations about america's pastime
something comes up baseball related
i said i want to tell danny oh i can't
you know look up at the sky and go hey
there and guess what you know
because of what they went through those
closest to daniel want everyone to keep
following health guidelines
this is such a violent pandemic and
they've taken so many lives already just
be courteous be considerate
and get vaccinated do it for the good of
those around you and although [ __ ]
still grapples with grief she knows
daniel's impact was immeasurable he left
behind a lot of people who really
cared about him
now daniel never married or had kids but
his family tells me he was very close to
his nieces and nephews
and he even left them his estate in an
effort to help them get ahead in life
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now